like my earrings oh my god of course
they're strawberries
is there anything you own that isn't
strawberry themed if there is
blue please strawberry
hello and welcome to another episode of
trash taste I'm your host for today
guards joining me once again are the
boys and we have a returning guest Emily
good to have you good to have you back
we decided to invite you back because uh
we needed someone back that could rival
uh shitty takes on Foods
we haven't roasted someone in a while
we we I we wanted this for a while uh
because it's uh this is like our
intervention well I mean but I also have
terrible taste I'm just here to be the
the free content Pig Dude the George
Foreman is getting turned on today we
are grilling okay so every so often I I
come on Twitter right uh and uh every so
often I see Emily tweezing most of the
time it's strawberry themed or something
about some Shoujo anime you're watching
I'm fine with that I'm fine with that
and then every time you have a food take
I just like I just have to like close
Twitter for the day
[Music]
the one that comes to mind most recently
I can't believe we're starting this off
and you're coming and Swinging like
minute one hey you've been there for
like how long have you been in Japan now
oh God almost a year yeah you came in
the show right when you got here yeah
yeah
stop I know I don't know
yeah not again it's been like 10 months
yeah we've been hanging out uh 10 months
we've been hanging out for like 10
months we've like lost all
preconceptions of just like having to be
nice when coming on the show or
something so you know
reoccurring yeah so at this point you
you know yeah you have to fit in yeah
he's having [__] takes and also we roast
each other okay the kitty gloves are off
so I'm ready to battle um so do you
wanna so one thing that comes to mind is
uh your tier list of noodles
so did you not see Emily's tier list of
uh like Japanese noodles no I don't know
what what did you say she tweeted it out
so Emily how would you like to rank
at the top we have udon that's cap
ID diet is here with me because he
agrees
here it's just number one okay number
one is it on yeah number two soba
okay
go on number three skimming okay
number four Ramen okay and then dead
last is summon okay well dead lost
soulmate that's that's an obvious
they're kind of like you know like other
noodles there's ramen noodles right just
in different ways do you want to join
explain what Simon is because I'm sure
is like I mean for one you usually only
eat it in the summer usually it's like
chilled um it's like the very clear
almost like rice noodles I don't
remember exactly what they made ramen
noodles I don't think they are I'm
[__] dumb they're not they're really
late yeah yeah I think they're kind of
like rice noodles where it's very thin
almost transparent white noodles yeah
you usually have with like a very very
simple like soy sauce based thing
usually you have it in the summer as
like a lunch like a very light lunch
it's the one where you know you've seen
it's like running on the river yeah
those things suck it's awful okay and
that is that is like universally normal
it's like the weakest noodles it's like
all my home all my homies hate so much
but you know there are there is like
maybe like once every couple of Summers
where I'm like I could kind of go for a
salmon lunch right now that's me with
Ramen
I think my problem is that you put udon
as the best noodle yeah
you had udon uh imagine Ramen you
quadrupled the thickness and it couldn't
absorb any of the flavor yeah it's like
it's like cement it's so thin so it's
okay okay look I you like I like udon
yeah but the fact that it's your number
one upsets you know what the fact that
you have two noodles above skin men is
like triggering okay well I haven't had
enough skimmick I'm gonna take the
inverse of hers
yeah yeah yeah because like I remember
when you posted that list I was like wow
you have literally posted this listen
opposite order almost I think I think in
the original tweet you posted Superman
at last and I was like Ramen was like
okay
it's just like I'm never no no I don't
think ramen's bad don't think that last
means bad yeah okay second to last in
this case right it's just the one that I
prefer the least okay like if you gave
me a menu yeah I will immediately gloss
over Robin like I won't even like okay
okay explain to me why udon is your
number one that's what I want to do what
is it about Udon that speaks to you the
noodles are nice and thick and chewy and
tasty and then the broth to like go with
the thickness of the noodles the broth
is nice and light why why are you saying
it's just like the worst mix of every
every Japanese noodle like the udon
Curry and it's like oh this is just
curry with cement no that's that's too
that's too heavy but the the udon broth
I love a good Kitsune udon where you got
that like tofu skin yeah I get that and
it's nice and then you get little side
of like tempura I think the most I've
ever eaten udon was when I had that
stomach flu because it's very light and
easy to digest yeah um but like if I'm
in a if I'm a healthy boy I'm not going
for udon yeah oh yeah udon is usually
for me it's like the sick food yeah if I
wanted something I guess light I'd
probably just go for like Sober Sober to
me is like lighter than udon yeah
yeah oh yeah soap is good but for me
udon's like a comfort food you know what
it's because I think so I used to live
in San Diego it was really hard to find
really good udon all right right so now
I feel like I've just developed a crush
I know why it's fun hard to get it on
because there is no
how dare you I realized that they were
like the guys were like I'm gonna roast
you for your shitty opinions I was like
I don't have one but then I realized no
there's one that hurt me there's one
that really okay okay all right guys so
there's this guy now yeah that's just
you yeah you know
there's this place in Hokkaido right
there's it's called it's called soup
curry MOG
mugs here this is like it's soup curry
right if you had a soup curry it's
literally it's not hard to figure out
it's curry in a super form yeah and this
place is it's like that this place is
insane it's it do the amount of spices
they put in there if you look on Google
dude it's crazy if you go to Toya you
got to go here it's the spot and Emily
was like it's fine and I was like no
it's fine
they would rival anything question out
of 10 what would you have given it like
an eight
what it was good you said it was good it
was mine usually is like six
no it was good I like none of it was bad
I just wouldn't travel an hour for it I
would I would
some meals are worth traveling an hour
for in my defense the breakfast we had
that day was monstrous if you remember
right right I feel like
fatigue hunger when I had that soup
curry so I need it I need to try again I
make room I make room all right yeah
yeah because you only ate like half your
breakfast and you were like I gotta save
them for soup curry yeah I mean that was
smart yeah yeah I've every time I've
gone to Hokkaido I've kind of made it
like a thing where I'm always I always
try to go there because it's probably
one of my favorite food spots in all of
Japan it's so good it's so good it's
cheap as well it's too cheap and he goes
up to this is when I knew this man was
the goat not only is it one to ten it
was like one to 30 or 20 spice levels
yeah and it was like five onwards is
habanero I'm like how how can we go
higher yeah
that's what impressed me about his spice
levels because there are some Japanese
chains that have like a ridiculous
amount of spice levels right they don't
mean [__] for the most places because
you all that matters is that when you
get to like the higher spice levels
you're basically just eating curry
powder yeah yeah that's why when you
have an area you're like oh we were
using real Peppers yeah yeah yeah we
care yeah I'm like what's level 30 just
[__] cyanide it's just a ball of
Hearts yeah it's just I like spice food
I get like four or five it's pretty damn
spicy like I can't imagine pushing it
yeah exactly it's I was impressed as a
Thai person I was like oh this is like
real spice it's real good spice as well
do you just not like strong flavors then
because maybe you don't you know what
maybe because I I can't handle spicy
right I don't like super sweet stuff
I don't like super sour stuff what do
you like I like it good cardboard you
are an enigma oh I like salty okay well
you like salty that's everything that's
true I think I just don't like I think I
have the palette of like a 65 year old
woman or six year old girl a sensitive
palette let's say yes because like you
put like tsukumen and ramen last which
is our like I'm pretty sure our favorite
oh yeah 100 yeah
um just because of like the nice thick
broth no I think it's just the nice
strong flavors if I get Ramen I take out
the meat
Titus
no I give it to Titus he likes the meat
[__] oh what I admit
the pork sometimes in the broth in the
ramen is really cheap really bad it can
be but you still eat it sometimes if
it's done right it's like my favorite
part of the ramen honestly because a lot
of the times the broth is built around
that yeah so it's like it's the broth
perfectly matches it it's called child
shoes
the broth has enough meaty flavor for me
and anything like the I like either rice
with like meat on it or I like meaty
broth with my noodles but if I have meat
on it it's too much I need to take that
I hate I hate it because I've had these
exact same arguments with Sydney because
she looks at you I'm like I I saw the
tear list and I looked and just like
looked at it in disgust and I'll show
you Sydney and she was like yes that's
my tail list as well I was like
[Laughter]
he also ranks oh no I think he ranks I
think for him it's udon soba it's given
wait no or skim and udon soba yeah no
he's I remember him saying skimming was
his favorite yeah yeah which is kids
which is good that's correct valid yeah
that that is the correct opinion that is
the correct answer so with sober do you
prefer cold sober oh okay thank God
thank God I'm a hot guy really I hate
that [__] cold
I don't know if this is I don't know
where this comes from in my head I'm
like man it just doesn't feel like a
meal unless it's hot is this is some
kind of brain thing I think I think it
is if I eat something and it's not hot
like if it's dessert yeah like dinner
like it cannot be dinner in my mind is
that why you can't eat sushi for dinner
yeah yeah it's often why I don't eat
sushi right yeah I will have it are
there some sushis that you won't go out
of your way right yeah I'd rather have
sushi for lunch all right yeah because
in my head something about it like I
don't know I don't know what kind of
just have a side Suites
yeah yeah again like I I do eat sushi
for dinner sometimes it's rare but a lot
of the times like I do not understand
cold soup I think cold soup is a crime
against soup I think no no no no no no
no
if somebody offers me cold soup I'm like
just [__] keep it it's it's all
dependent on the environment man of
course French people are like what do
you what the [__] do you mean
someone's day sometimes you just get
like a nice refreshing cold soup as a
starter and it just like hot drinks when
it's a hot day I like cold drinks on
cold days yeah I don't know how I for
some for some reason when I drink hot
tea this this just felt like an AI
generated yeah I like hot drinks on hot
days
maybe you feel the same way but when I
drink a hot drink on a hot day for some
reason I feel like it cools me down what
yeah I don't know why you call me wait
wait repeat what you just said so I can
fully it doesn't make any sense wait so
you you feel like a hot drink the hot
drink cools you down but it heats up
your body yeah but I I think it's like I
don't know something about it it feels
kind of kind of right see I I kind of
get what you mean because like if you
have a hot tea okay because I prefer
eating ice creams I was gonna [__]
same brain cell right again I remember
colder the day is the more I'm like
[__] no that's different I I actually
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait how's
that different that's different
in eating cold ice cream on a cold day
because I know it's gonna stay colder so
it's not right because you don't you
don't see it no yeah because okay yeah
it like it holds its shape longer so you
get that it's at its peak ice cream it
tastes better on a cold today I I I I
think both ways because I actually like
don't like eating ice cream on a hot day
I I know that sounds counter-intuitive
but to me on a hot day I want something
refreshing and when I have like a thick
ice cream that's one the opposite of
refreshing
um and two it's just gonna melt faster
yeah right and on a cold day I'm
probably gonna be less thirsty and it's
just something nice about having like a
nice
thick ice cream like a Hokkaido ice
cream on a Winter's day next to the snow
I don't know I just like all ice cream
at all periods because ice cream is the
best [__] dessert
this is like when you guys laughed at me
we went to the restaurant and it was
like this really fancy restaurant and
everyone was getting these desserts that
were extremely like it was like it's a
mushroom caved in as a chocolate truffle
and then Joey's like I'll have the I'll
have the falombe uh flipped inside out
15. I'm like I have ice cream
I'm a single scoop of ice cream
of vanilla ice cream yeah I remember and
everyone laughed I ordered it because
everyone was going on this tirade of
extremely extravagant desserts did
dessert was really really [__] good
and they put like they put effort into
designing these really really intricate
desserts yeah and they looked they all
not only looked ecstatic but they tasted
really really good
um and and then no because I get it
because it's like if it's at like a bog
standard like you know run-of-the-mill
restaurant that has desserts then I will
also opt to get like a single scoop of
ice screen but if you're at like a fancy
restaurant or like a restaurant that has
like I don't need this desserts that
actually are crafted and uh unique then
yeah I'm gonna try it out like I'm not a
huge dessert person but I'm like okay
that looks kind of unique I'm like the
complete opposite of you because if if I
go to a normal place and they just like
have bog standard desserts I'm just not
gonna have dessert the only the only
reason I'll go out of my way to have
dessert if it's if it's like a little
bit extravagant a little bit yeah
something special it's like the steak
right it's like uh you know in every
restaurant like steak is the indication
of how you can how good your restaurant
is right if you cook a steak yeah same
with ice cream you can if you can give
me good ice cream then your desserts
must be pretty [__] good if you can
get a vanilla ice cream but you never
order anything but vanilla ice cream
would you know we're back
I consider something Connor only because
it is two things vanilla ice cream and
Tiramisu that's like anything else on
the menu is just like well disgusting
what's that uh what's that The Italian
Dish called the one where it's like
cream and like oh I like creme brulee no
no
I just think that fruit is always [__]
um
I think that vegetables Trump fruits in
every single way well yeah and I don't
want I don't want I have no time no but
like you know in a meal right that makes
sense but like what about the dessert
I'd just rather not I just have
something like like an ice cream
where'd they bring it out because
they're obsessed with desserts fruit
desserts yeah I love it I [__] hate
it
fruit
the fruit's so good here right now it's
fine I just I just preferred an ice
cream or a Tiramisu or something you're
not even obsessed with it other than
strawberries do you guys ever get those
frozen mango chunks from 7-Eleven oh
yeah yeah yeah they're so cool
killing like two bags at night
it's like it's like it's like a having a
little sorbet between your fingertips
those are really good so clean I was at
first I was kind of sauce about it
because I'm like oh that's a really
cheap for a bag of rice because usually
you know when you get actual mangoes in
Japan they're like cost 20 000 for them
yeah yeah so when I saw like how much
are they they're like 200 candles
they're like 200 yen for about 200 yen
for a frozen mangoes like decent size
like that and I'm like oh I'll give it a
go and I had it so it's so good so good
in the summer I do like bananas I just
realized that I like breakfast but I
wouldn't have it as dessert
not even like a banana bread like a
banana split the [__] no that shit's
awful what wait so you don't like any
fruits but bananas basically no I do
like fruits I just there's never an
occasion where I would want a fruit over
a vegetable I don't know why I'm just
like even in any situation yeah I think
I just always prefer vegetables what if
it's a really hot day vegetables I'm
what if you wanted a smoothie
oh my God
what am I I don't ever go for like the
super fruity ones I'll get the ones
where they put all the green [__] in it
because it tastes good
I mean I get that but sometimes you it's
a hot day and you're like yeah I could
go for like a mango smoothie or like a
hot tea
no I remember in Thailand everybody was
like yo let's go to the store get a
mango smoothie get like a watermelon
smoothie yeah
Connor being the [__] British person
he's just like do you have hot tea
it's like 30 degrees Yeah
unfortunately Connor didn't realize that
99 of drinks in Thailand come with like
a bucket full of ice no matter where you
go oh yeah they they gave me I had this
um I tried uh Thai tea yeah [__] hell
this is sweet yeah oh yeah yeah can you
do it without the sugar I asked her on
the plane I was like can I have a tea
without sugar and she was like yeah it
doesn't have sugar in it I'm like no no
this one's super sweet can I have one
that isn't sweet no it just comes with
sugar she was like what that's not
that's just tea yeah me I was like I
want this tea this tea you've given me
but way less sweet it's like can't be
done
I was like I know it I know you have it
I know you have it give it to me have
you ever had like Southern sweet tea
yeah yeah it's awful that shit's [__]
gross yeah it is it is of course you
like that no I don't no no no I don't
like it when super sweet but I went to
Alabama once and I had some of the best
peach iced tea I've ever had in my life
yeah it might it might be good if you
put enough sugar in it
the first time I had it was in uh in
Atlanta and I tried it because my friend
was like yo you should try this it's
it's you know it's Southern tea and I'm
like okay let's see how it is bro it was
like sugar water yeah literally it is
sugar water it's yeah I want to make it
uh it's gonna make it palatable right
because tea is hard to drink if you're
not generationally pressured into it I
mean not every culture gets tea but what
state did we do a show at that they
voted like the top thing America does
best and they voted like tea and oh yeah
some of them some of them thought they
did tea better than anywhere else yeah
that was insulting where was this oh oh
it was uh it's one of the Southern
States oh that makes sense no I don't
even think it was I think it was like
was it nice it was the state that they
threw all the tea into the ocean what
state was that oh Boston Boston yeah
Massachusetts yeah I think it was
Massachusetts right Austin's in
Massachusetts right okay
better than anyone else I'm like oh
really
I do remember that yes
I'm really hoping you guys were trolling
yeah so okay what okay what do you hate
about lamb
a lot of people didn't like that I
basically I heard that you didn't like
lemon my response was let's try
everything why did they not like that I
think because they were like that's how
you pressure someone into hating
something more no no no I I went into it
with an open mind yeah yeah no I don't
agree with that stuff but but the the
thing that you said that I don't mind if
you don't like lamb I mean I am offended
but it's okay it tastes Dusty yeah the
thing that you said that that made me
think like huh was that you said it
tastes like goat's cheese no Dinah said
that I didn't say that diet
it tastes I can't Emily explain it Emily
no I actually kind of agree with you no
yeah I've been I've been holding this in
I've been because
for the longest time I was like I kind
of like didn't like lamb uh as well just
because it has this like really weird
aftertaste yeah it gets me yeah and is
it like the gaminess
you gotta get that checked out and like
the goat cheese thing it's uh I I the
the reason I was put off by goat's
cheese is because it did have this
aftertaste and it kind of reminded me of
the Lamb after taste but like even
stronger so I kind of get what Titus is
talking about
um Those cheese also tastes Dusty what
the [__] I love it
I mean ghost stories isn't my favorite
but Dusty is not the worst
I can't I just it's such a bizarre
flavor I can't describe the effort I
know a lot of people who don't like lamb
saying that like it tastes very like
earthy or like um very gamey is the word
you know that they use where it smells
like a wild animal yeah I I just like
when people eat deer feel the same way
yeah it is good it is good yeah it
doesn't have that same I've never had
Bears so I don't know like how gamey
that is I noticed when we were eating
meat it was like the closer it tasted to
a meat you recognized you were like this
is good
taste I think deer tastes closer to beef
than it does oh definitely yeah yeah
yeah I think it does okay but here is
considered more gameier than lamb well
here's the thing I used to like really
really hate loud because I'd already get
like really cheap Cuts right and then
once I started getting like proper like
you know America like Australian lamb
chops and stuff like that I was like oh
this actually slaps pretty hard yeah so
I'm sorry what you're from the UK what
are you talking about why are you
picking up there left we have we have
some of the best
actually actually I'm sorry I think it's
UK that put me off land for the longest
time because I think I think
I think the aftertaste in the UK lamb is
just wait all at least the ones I had in
fact
wow look anytime we'd have lamb at like
any roasts like dinners or like any it
was mostly like school lunches that put
me off land because it was like
obviously it wasn't good cuts of lamb
because there were [__] school
dinners you guys got lamb at school
lunches again it's very abundant yeah we
had a lot there's more sheep in Wales
than people oh that's true yeah so I'd
had it a lot in like school
um and I just hated this weird
aftertaste every time I didn't get lamb
in school though did you not no what the
[__]
lamb is mad expensive in Australia do
they barely gave us pasta
sometimes you'd have like you know there
was a special occasion where they'd have
like a kind of like roast there was like
the cheapest kind of available
damn they gave you food almost yeah wow
yeah I mean it wasn't good cuts of them
obviously because to me it tastes like
[__] put me offline for the longest time
only got into lamb actually when you had
the good lamp yeah when I had the good
lamp probably like in my span of moving
to Japan actually because I just avoided
lamb for my entire life but it still if
it's like a cheap cut of lamb a lot of
the times I just I just can't handle it
so so you like the expensive lamb now
like you like lamb but only if it's the
good cut yes okay I mean that's me with
steak like if it's a good cut of steak
then I like it but I was kind of the
same with you like I grew up eating a
lot of like really cheap cuts of like
beef steak so it's like it kind of put
me over for the longest time and then
when I moved to Japan I had a really
good cut of steak and I'm like oh steak
can be good wow
what are you talking about Australian
steak is still good though Joey yeah but
like you can also get like it's like
lamb in the UK where it's like it's very
abundant like you can get the really
cheap Cuts but you can also get the
really expensive cuts okay I guess the
ones I ate my whole life were just like
mostly the really cheap Cuts because I
didn't have any money growing up so it's
like yeah oh this is not that great yeah
because it's kind of took you two
Genghis Khan yeah to in Hokkaido right
what was your impression of that
just stamp one now
Emily just be honest be honest I'm an
ally I'm an ally he's a safe space safe
space it was not for me
I would not go again but I am glad I can
finally like put it to rest I just don't
like lamb you mean you don't like lamb
tongue huh oh no yeah I had like
everything yeah yeah it was like lamb
tall no that's the kid everything I do
like that's the best part
that's my favorite thought no I'm not a
fan of tongue in general I think I don't
I don't like the texture it's too chewy
it's too don't like don't like British
lamb don't like [__] time
wait what's it wait what's your favorite
cut of the yakin yuku my favorite cuts
um if you don't like Tom
and he's anything but just hung like I I
[__] love like 90 of cuts except for
the tongue okay question question okay
you go to Yakitori right okay what's
your go-to you order you can order one
stick from a Yakitori place what are you
ordering oh negative 100 yeah me too
what do you got I don't really like
yakitorial okay
[Laughter]
but there'll be a video out on your
Channel at some point where we'll be
going over all this stuff in more detail
oh my God okay okay
since we were on the topic of fruits you
know how last time when I was here I
said I wanted to bring fruit as like
gifts yeah you didn't I brought fruit
this time oh hell yeah I'll take I'll
take Corners might change his opinion
wait no wait hold on let it cook could
be a banana
hold up hold up hold up listen listen
listen okay I I'm being hyperbolic in a
sense when I'm saying I don't uh like
any fruit but there's just a lot of the
time I prefer veg just give him oranges
that would be you give me a [__]
orange though are you a devil okay they
don't they don't unfortunately I don't
think luxury bananas are a thing
oh I don't I don't think there are
things they're not exactly the most like
High Class A bunch of dolls
bananas so I just got the most expensive
one that they had which was like which
was like 240 Yen
all the cats you know I appreciate that
he's getting value for his money man I'm
getting a guy for money
Joey I know your favorite's watermelon
but watermelon is not in season yeah
unfortunately I don't know do you like
these whatever these are like you do
yeah what is that it looks tumorous that
looks like
like orange on steroids that isn't that
is a roided orange
that's me like my two boys when I leave
the answer that's what they look like
yeah so these are Deco bone which are
like a type of uh Orange it's like a
it's like an orange uh Mandarin it's
just like the [__] liver King if he
wasn't orange strawberries [__] yeah you
know I'm always loving strawberries the
favorite friend is yeah
my fellow lamb haters where you at
only did you get strawberries you also
got the the luxurious yeah
that's just bomb the the the white ones
yeah
only in Japan but they were like let's
make our strawberries anemic
I've always been curious because I've
always wondered what yeah thank you
thank you very much yeah why do you love
strawberries so much because one of the
first match
because when we first met I remember you
saying oh yeah I like strawberries I'm
like I like strawberries too but then
like I cut like slowly over the 10
months do I realize oh you really like
it was like I like like strawberries you
know that Meme of like that's like the
one with the dudes like mem on one thing
and it's disgusting this is strawberries
for Emily with one thing and it's
disgusting oh my God the strawberry bag
it's a very very cute bag it's from the
artist Nina fresas on Twitter
and you also have the other variations
you have two of those I do I got I got
one strawberry version yeah
one for a different day yeah so yeah so
why do you love it everything about it
it's just it's it's beautiful I love the
look of it I love how they taste like
strawberries have always been like my
number one favorite fruit for the
longest time but then like I don't know
you see strawberry printed stuff and
it's like the cutest it is pretty cute I
think aesthetically they're they're very
nice did you survive yeah okay okay yeah
like I I do like the look of
strawberries but like I feel like it's
usually they are pretty usually like the
dolphins of fruit yeah like I like the
most loved and most revered and they
look pretty and they yeah they're kind
of nice like you look at a strawberry
cake and you're like oh that is so
beautiful it's probably out of the fruit
Kingdom it's probably the cutest fruit
it is it is I think out of like
in the fruit Kingdom it very much gels
with Japanese kind of like Japanese
culture as well right you can you can
have expensive looking strawberries you
can have small adorable smaller yeah
yeah exactly a giga chatter because it
doesn't care it's got its own packaging
I hit it with the [__] did you when
you're in Thailand did you try any Thai
bananas I thought what the little ones
the little ones yeah I tried it it was
nice I think I prefer these though I
like I like the little ones
it's like bite sizes to me that's the
perfect size banana yeah this is the
goat he likes the thicker and girthier
than he does they're self-packaged they
don't break easily they come in a bunch
I'm just thinking is there any fruit is
there any fruit that's more aesthetic
than a strawberry uh I mean there's lots
of Aesthetics fruits out there but they
don't taste very good I mean it's good
you know it reminds you of Bob it's kind
of nice you know I just not they're the
it's they're the prettiest I mean people
love you like these melons do look cool
yeah the one when they're all like
perfect and they have all the you buddy
middle yeah yeah yeah yeah but what
about like the way I'm paying like what
about the uh Japanese like square
watermelons have you seen those yeah
I've never seen one yeah I've seen them
and I've have had one before
do you know how they make them is it
like a special breed do they
specifically make them grow yeah
and they grow it in a box yeah and then
it it fills out I don't know who figured
this out that you could do this why have
we done this with bananas why have we
not done this with like more fruit
these were Square they'd be so much
easier to like I just realized it's a
[__] dance like why don't they do
some bananas because it [__] grows on
a tree
I'll put the Box on the thing just hang
a bunch of boxes like it would be like
Minecraft already at the most like
Optimal [__] it is perfect I just wish
that it you could like put it in like a
shelf and you can just
like opening a banana is the most fun
opening of any fruit
and peel as much as you want to eat and
that's just great it is the most
optimized food it is the most optimized
fruit to be fair and we're having fun
did you know for most of my life I
actually opened Bernard I hated opening
bananas because I did this is like this
like my something went wrong with my
childhood clearly somewhere uh because
for some reason my my childhood my child
brain was like oh you open it from this
side you must open it from this side
because this is this is where the gunk
is so they give you a handle yeah I know
I know now I realize that okay okay all
right all right all right okay wow you
think
you think you open it from here
no no no no listen gone all right I've
watched a monkey eat a banana this is
when I learned that we are [__]
stupid we go for the handle like this
okay monkeys open banana no they just do
this they just squeeze like that
[Music]
just squeeze that that's what the
monkeys do and I realized when I first
saw that I was like God damn it that's
why that's why they know it that's why
it's definitely go that's why they're
the best animals isn't it just as fast
to pull it no try it do it as fast as I
don't want to eat it I'll eat it
that's actually how I used to open them
that was lucky that was lucky
sometimes it makes dude
this is the optimizer why do you think
the monkeys do it they don't [__] around
with the top is it also because they
don't have thumbs yeah it smells good it
does yeah because okay this is all three
this is no only one I mean okay never
mind
as far as when I squeeze at the top I
mean oh goodbye not really yeah I mean I
I feel like they've they are exactly the
same Technique No no no
because like when when you start off
with this end you get like the little
Gunk no no it's fine because sometimes
you do it from the top right and
sometimes it doesn't it doesn't break
perfectly and then it's like oh [__] no
if it doesn't break perfectly then I
know the banana is like
determine the work of the banana or
somehow nice no you can't you can't
because because if if the skin isn't
firm enough then to me that banana is
like too far gone
you know sometimes there's we've talked
about this there's a perfect amount of
ripeness that everyone loves with their
own bananas and I love it like this this
to me is like the perfect banana right
if if it's if the Skin's gone a bit too
soft uh if it's got like a bit of
Browning or like some spots are starting
then it's sweetest yeah as a kid I
didn't understand how ripeness worked I
didn't understand why my friend's house
at his house his bananas always tasted
way better than when my mum bought them
I realized I was just eating them when
they were basically green
it was hard
damn what is why does his taste so much
better by the way this is this is really
looking like a JoJo family
this episode is sponsored by boxu guys
Sakura season is finally here are you
guys excited and you'd be excited to
know that boxu is also hyped up for the
Sakura season and that's why they're
bringing to you the Sakura season
special boxes look at this beautiful box
oh look at that look how pink it is
boxer delivers the experience of tasting
authentic Japanese snacks candies and
tea sauce directly from Century's old
small family businesses right to your
door their mission is to empower Japan's
traditional snack makers by sharing the
authentic food and stories with the
world look at all these beautiful snacks
we've got here Connor take one what is
that going on yeah trust boxes so much
I'm gonna let you pick the snack for me
I'm gonna get some Sakura zinsen
actually I I thought you couldn't pick
the snack for me Joe it's okay it's okay
it's okay for me just
headquarters and steel the rest of these
so if you want to have your own Sakura
celebration and support our Channel
click the link in the description and
use code trash to get 15 off your order
negative boxer for sponsoring this video
back to the episode you win in Japan now
for nearly a year have your uh thoughts
changed on everything over that year
since you've been here
I love it oh my God what's the main
takeaways that you've kind of felt over
the past few months yeah like how do you
just thinks about Japan yeah like what
are some things you love more
yeah yeah some things you don't like oh
oh man where do I even start first of
all the food oh
so freaking good yeah not not had
tipping not being a thing oh my oh my
God oh my God
um
what are some like culture shock moments
for me
um do you still experience it you think
like in everyday life or are you kind of
like past it now after you I think I've
I'm pretty much like used to everything
it's just like recently the thing that
made me do like a double take is I'm not
used to seeing like little ass kids
walking by themselves at like the train
station yes that still shocks me I'll be
walking with Titus and it'll be like 8
p.m and we're walking home from the
train station I just see like a
six-year-old with this big ass backpack
walking past and we're like where are
your parents yeah where are your parents
like I feel like if I would have a kid
in Japan that would be the one thing
that would [__] terrify me yeah it's
scary just being like Oh you're three
years old now off you go on to the train
with you yeah I didn't notice that they
do put a lot of trust into their kids
here just to get around by themselves
yeah but uh even just like even not even
on the train like just sometimes I'd be
walking back from like the office or
wherever I am and then there would just
be like a four-year-old walking home
from Like Preschool by themselves and
I'm like are you are you lost how do you
know your way back yeah how do you know
your way back I didn't I barely died
I could barely get around my own house
when I was four years yeah let alone
like the neighborhood you know so it's
like every time I see them I always
think like are you lost like are you
okay it's got to be a plan by the police
kids actually commute yeah it's because
they want to get them into the salary
man life immediately they're like start
commuting yeah get into it also the kids
are so cute I say that in like the least
weird way I possibly can just like yeah
like okay I feel like I think it was
weird and that you said that yeah
it was it wasn't weird thank you because
like because I feel like in America
people like to dress their kids to look
like many adults a lot of the times
I guess really do they yeah well like
they buy honestly I've never looked this
was Americans who wear [__] t-shirts
everywhere well they buy them like I've
noticed that a lot of parents buy their
kids like little miniature versions of
like what they wear so it's like I'll
match with mommy
you know but like it just looks weird
because it's like that's a toddler in
like a supreme sweater what are you
doing
but no no I'm trying to remember what I
wore as a kid
oh my fashion is horrendous [__] my
parents would allow me to wear a happy
yeah I'm just wondering did my parents
dress me up like them no I don't think
they did you know you know what was one
of my favorite shows growing up I'm sure
someone can uh can relate it was the
Flaming slasher shirt did you ever see
those oh actually you know I know every
kid in our generation like there was at
least one kid that was like black shirt
with like Flames coming from the bottom
yeah and a slasher logo I liked wearing
the school uniform because then on
weekends I was like [__]
you know what to wear you still what's
up
I remember if I had a thought as a kid I
was like man I wish you'd wear my school
uniform every day so I don't think I
hate wearing my school uniform I loved
it because I was like great were you
just going and then and then because you
go home and you watch American TV and
they're all bullying each other for not
wearing certain clothes or looking like
a nerd it's like was that weird no we
don't have that problem yeah cause we
all West school uniforms you don't have
uniforms in America do you most schools
don't no no it's only like privates yeah
only if it's like private school or like
Catholic schools you don't have to worry
about [__]
it is nice but at the same time it's
like one less thing to get bullied about
a lot of other stuff yeah
I remember anyone ever getting I don't
think I've ever witnessed anyone at my
school getting bullied for like what
they were wearing yeah and why is it
such like a common Trope in like
American High School films
well I'm not basing it off that well I
mean I have seen that but yeah yeah I
just assumed because kids are the worst
kids will do anything yeah yeah but kids
won't pick clothes they'll find your
deepest insecurities and they'll and
they'll they're evil our kids are evil
sometimes I know chill not Japanese kids
though they're adorable as [__] oh until
they hit High until they hit high school
that's when they become evil you know
and then they learn about bullying and
they're like
they've got like their little like their
little yellow boxes
like big ass backpacks that are like
twice their size it's so cute have you
ever seen like when the teachers leading
like a group of school kids yeah they're
so [__] adorable it makes my day so
much better just seeing like this line
of like these these kids just and the
teacher at the front being like okay
let's go yeah they're crossing the road
Nursery yeah
20 kids in this car I think she'll be
dragging it around oh that's cute I
think it is pretty adorable to see now
what what happened earlier like last
year when when ditus and I just moved
into our apartment uh we we'd like
we weren't used to like saying hello to
like neighbors or like strangers yeah
but now it's like pretty normal there
was this little kid that walked past us
in like our apartment hallway thing
right
and as we weren't expecting him to say
anything but as we were walking by he
was like
and we're like oh
and so we're like oh okay like so we do
gotta say I don't know I thought maybe
it'd be weird if I just like said hi to
like the kids yeah so then later that
same day we saw another kid by our
apartment complex as we're walking back
diet is looks at him he's like oh
konnichiwa and the kid's like
so you gotta wait for the kids yeah yeah
yeah
he stars at you yeah yeah pretty yeah
like he just stared and we were like oh
sorry sorry my my favorite one that
that's really cute as well but like I
recently had one where like I was coming
back from uh from somewhere and near my
apartment there was this kid that just
like kept staring at me while I was
waiting for the lights and I'm just like
you good kid you're good what's up and
then I crossed the road and as he was
crossing the road he runs past me and
stops in front of me and goes
all right you be careful
where your parents
that's adorable so cute yeah
get off the road yeah kids in Japan no
matter what they do like if they they or
you know kids are curious and sometimes
they either go out their way to say
hello and it's like when they like ask
you questions as well then you just
they're so cute they just just like if
you ever come to Japan and you uh you
you know what we're talking about when
you see like a group of kids walking
walking along they're like you said like
a group of ducklings yeah crossing the
road right even though it's just
something about the aesthetic you know I
don't know it's the little yellow hats
and the and like the backpacks it's a
Vibe aesthetic toddler core yeah
what the [__]
[__] I gotta ask uh as someone who
really really likes desserts and I guess
like sweeter things and aesthetic things
you don't
no
wow this you'd [__] no I don't know
I've never seen you get excited over
anything that wasn't dessert what do you
mean you heard me it
it's I get a difference I get excited
for strawberry
okay
big difference
okay so just I was gonna see that just
ruins my I was going to ask if you've
discovered like a Japanese dessert that
you like but if you don't like desserts
oh
um I like
don't say what I just feel I feel like
you're gonna say what I like she okay
okay
I don't know just like the plain one
with like the soy sauce that one's
really good yeah but yeah I don't I
don't I don't really like desserts do
you like Ichigo daifu the one that has
oh my God yeah okay of course that was a
dumb question
I like to to get it and then get like an
extra pack of strawberry so that when I
run out of strawberry I can stick
another one back in I like reset it's so
good it's so you reload the Mochi with
another strawberry it's so because
there's never one strawberry is not
enough for one Ichigo daifuka you need
yes
what are you talking about Emily goes to
the [__] strawberry farm and just
reloads the entire apartment perfectly
engineered that so the Mochi the
strawberry ratio is like perfect so that
maybe you're left with like a tiny
little bit of emoji at the end no it's a
clowns I need more strawberries that is
one of the things that I'm really happy
about since moving here the strawberries
are so freaking good yeah except uh they
only come around like once a year yeah
yeah unfortunately Japan is so dependent
especially the third they're so
dependent on Seasons we're just like I
don't know man I feel this fruit here is
good enough where you could have it all
year round like I don't think it'd be
that much of an issue really could they
grow it in the winter in the summer I
don't know I mean like I mean I feel
like when you go to like a supermarket
in like any other country I feel this
just like the whole collection of fruits
all year round I don't know yeah but
sometimes the fruit tastes better in
certain seasons of my local grocery
store I can always tell like what season
it is based on oh yeah well in Japan I
mean like in different countries yeah
yeah like you go to like any kind of
Supermarket like America or Australia
whatever and it's like they have all of
the fruits there yeah all year round and
I'm like Japan could do that but they're
just like it's not in season let's not
sell it and I'm like because it's not at
its peak yeah I'm like but something
sometimes it's like it could be like
this right now winter and I'm like I
kind of want to have some watermelon but
they don't [__] sell watermelon in
everywhere so I'm just sad drinking
the amount of like watermelon like
smoothies not smoothies watermelon uh
mixes I don't know like the I've
forgotten the English name the amount of
watermelon drinks you guys got in
Thailand was like [__] ridiculous oh
yeah it was either watermelon or
coconuts
because it's expensive here very good
Coconut's [__] great I just like the
fresh coconuts yeah same here like very
good I I rarely have coconut if it's not
you know in the Southeast Asian country
or if it's like grown there because I
remember like for a long time Sydney
just like hated coconut and she was she
was like I don't like coconut water I
don't like coconut anything but I didn't
like it either yeah and then and then we
moved to Thailand and she was like I
[__] love coconut and I'm like Sydney
when you're out of the country you're
gonna be chasing that high and no matter
what the no matter what coconut juice
coconut water you get it's never gonna
you can't buy the package stuff ever
again no no you can't it's just
something about that freshness of the
coconut there though yeah you'll spend
your life chasing that high you know
like no canned coconut drink or whatever
will ever meet up
what's your favorite food in Thailand
I'm curious because someone as someone
who doesn't like strong flavors and
strong taste that's like 90 of Thai food
well I did Gorge myself on the fruit for
sure because I knew it would be able to
get the same stuff here mango coconut
watermelon was just oh my God the mango
sticky rice okay mango sticking my
[__] slaps yeah that's like your
worth yeah it's like a worse
every fried egg I had in Thailand was
delicious yeah crispy everything was
delicious even the stuff that was like
too spicy for me I like I was like damn
this is still really
yeah it's so good dude I felt bad in
Thailand because we ordered room service
one night
um we brought in this amazing food and
they they said it all out for us and it
was it was like way too much yeah from
them I think we'd have been happy they
were just like
yeah and so he brings out like the thing
to tip and I was like oh yeah I'll tip
him yeah sure let's [__] time write
down a number and I'm like nice we
tipped him he leaves I'm like
oh [__] I just tipped him like 30 cents
I gave him in my head I was like I'm
gonna give him 20 bucks
you know and then I realized oh [__] I
gave him three like 30 cents and I was
like oh my God and then of course when
we're done with it we call them up right
and yeah man I really wanted to correct
it but I was like man how do I okay can
you come back to the room I've got more
money for you oh they didn't come back
right now we I called so I was like Hey
we're done with the food same dude comes
back and I'm like yeah dude
sorry about that
um he's a real test since I gave him a
bunch and he was like no no no no no no
I'm just I just like doing this it's
fine no no please take it please and
then I was like I got money too I just
felt so walking about that sorry that
you've been burning in my memory
we made up for it yeah I wonder what's
more offensive no tip or 30 cents
at least no tip it's like you weren't
even trying [__] pretending like we
bought like a [__] hundred dollar
room service thing yeah
probably I would be thinking do they
feel good about this
it's like giving a dollar to the
homeless person be like I've done my
good deal for the day you know I am I'm
a Good Samaritan today
what do you what do you think about um
because you've been in Japan for a while
yeah uh the architecture do you compared
to like American one or like when you're
walking do you like how it's more
walkable here or I do oh my God I love
that I don't have to drive
um
I was so yeah I was so happy when I
finally like sold my car and I was like
I don't have to worry about this again I
don't have to pay for registration yeah
for as long as I live if you can yeah I
can just walk it's great I love public
transportation I think you might uh try
and drive it all here nope
next question any reason for that well I
don't think I could rewire my brain to
be on the other side of the road do you
mean the correct side of the road sure
the correct side of the road I feel like
I don't know I just I I already feel
nervous I feel that way when I think
about every time I go to America and I'm
like maybe I should get an international
license but then I think about I'm like
I'm gonna crash yeah yeah if I try I
don't know
I've driven in America before this is
scary
it's [__] terrifying it's holy [__] I
just drive different dude Americans they
have nothing to lose I already didn't
like driving in America like it's just I
don't know it's a scary experience
especially if you're driving in La yeah
you don't drive aggressive in L.A like
you just don't get anywhere exactly
aggressive which is terrified I hate I
just like following the rules yeah
driving yeah why does everyone drive
like they have three stars on GTA like
it's like what are you running away from
they do they do because they probably do
they probably do yeah I will say like
coming from like a British driving
license because even in Thailand you
drive on the left side of the road as
well intersections are the most
terrifying things I've experienced my
life driving in America just because
there are so
lame yeah the amount oh my God
she's like I don't even know where it's
just a [__] be okay when you go in
the middle and you wait in the middle
because it's like maybe the light change
you're like I'm yeah yeah
I mean it ran from both sides yeah
because like I remember everything like
first time I started driving in America
luckily I was driving in [__]
Wisconsin but even in Wisconsin three
other drivers yeah even Wisconsin still
[__] terrifying because I don't know
if like the guy next to me has had like
two pints or whatever or five pints God
knows if it's in Wisconsin you know what
scares me is that just how big the cars
are in America yeah when I'm driving
like if if a [__] k-car hit me in
Japan I'm like all right well his car
gets demolished maybe I get a bruise you
know what I mean in America it's like
we've got the new Chevy t150 built with
Industrials Titanium on the front
everything in your past if you need a
ram a liberal off the road it's like
it's like they're gigantic
the trucks yeah like you feel like just
any Collision feels like definitely like
deadly in America oh yeah when I first
started like when I I was new to driving
at like age 19. yeah
um any I don't do it anymore obviously
but anytime I had to like
pass or like drive past like an
18-wheeler I would scream the entire
time
you're like
I had to be like a good distance away
that I'm like okay
wait why with passengers too you scream
what did you oh especially with
passengers oh my God I'm like here we go
I'd be like so yeah I'm thinking like
this
anyway what was I saying uh
why it's scary
full-on screaming the whole time I
understand screaming in your head yeah
oh but not out loud yeah oh that's just
a psychotic breakdown I'm like no I mean
I got over it I think my mum did a
similar thing actually because she was
telling me when she had driving lessons
uh did you have to like learn emergency
brakes in American like driving school
emergency brakes like the no so so it's
a handbrake yeah
like when you're on a hill no no no no
no it's like you need to immediately
stop yeah in the British test you have
to that there might be a thing where the
guy just goes all right emergency stop
and you just fall on just don't matter
how fast you're going full-on stop yeah
no oh we don't know yeah so we won't be
on a busy road no no it will be it'll
test you on a quiet road but they teach
you the technique of how to basically
slam the clutch in a safe manner right
so so you're not like swerving
everywhere
um so you sometimes get tested on it in
in British Driving School uh but I
remember my mom telling me that she was
incapable
um every time they would ask her to
practice the emergency stop she wasn't
capable of doing it without screaming at
Full Tilt
so
how it goes right is you're driving on
this really quiet Road and then the
instructor will just go stop and
normally you just slam on the brakes but
my mom was telling me every time the
instructor goes stop she's going
they don't take out points for that dude
I'm I I would
probably a minor right
something
it's so funny though yeah you said Japan
is very walkable in the cities when you
get out of it it's very very not yes
yeah have you had a chance to live visit
outside of Tokyo a lot because I know
everyone is like moved to Japan I'm like
they're like I'm gonna go I'm gonna go
[__] explore outside of Tokyo I'm
gonna explore so much for Japan a year
passes and you're like I've been nowhere
yeah no
times that
have traveled outside of Tokyo Conor's
driven yeah I've been uh
you know it's chill it's way better than
public transport oh my God because you
can just listen to music and like talk
uh you can do that on the train yeah
well I'm not like you can't listen to
the music with the boys you know what I
mean you can't blast it oh my God you
know it's just more fun I guess because
it's like you're so used to public
transport here that when you do get the
chance to have that expert like the vibe
of being in a car with your friends like
yeah hell yeah I'll take that well it is
yeah like it's a luxury but I mean I
mean I think there's a difference
between you know going on a road trip
with the boys and uh commuting an hour
every day via car which a lot of people
do yeah so you know yeah yeah you know
that's that's you know two very
different experiences because there is
definitely a vibe that I love about just
blasting the mute like you're in the
driver's side you're in the driver's
seat and you're blasting the music that
you want to [__] blast yeah of course
you know and just like swamping it down
the highway side in Japan when there's
like they got like such cool roads and
like you have really cool like Mountain
uh like Bridges and
that was weird that was so weird yeah so
I want to go Costco and then we were
like let's just do like a little Airbnb
where we chill out and Countryside
barbecue and eat Costco food and so we
went
um to me you made it sound like it was
just you made it sound like we went to
Chiba just for Costco I'd do that too
yeah we did get that too we went to uh
we went to Costco got a bunch of
barbecue stuff and then went out and
then um we went to Narita which is the
airport right yeah I'd never been to
Naruto and I think most people as well
I've never been to Naruto outside of the
airport so we went to some camping place
in Naruto which is lovely now it's just
really nice that the shrines were
awesome it was just a giant one uh in
the city center
um but this the guy who ran the Airbnb
was weird
was nice but he was he came and like
drank with us and then got like hammered
and passed out
so he lived opposite and then he came
over he's like how you guys doing
Japanese guy uh polish I think yeah oh
oh okay he was like so I think he was
just like he lived far away from his
wife or something as well sounded kind
of lonely and they sound like he didn't
have any friends who came up was like so
hey guys joined the Airbnb here I'm like
yeah that's good we drinking like Spears
like oh okay mind if I join I'll be like
all right sure I guess he was just nice
yeah this was nice it was nice it was
just funny that he passed out and I know
he didn't pass down trusting us huh yeah
yeah I've never had an Airbnb oh no come
yeah that's a bit weird yeah it was
definitely odd it was definitely like
you felt like you didn't sign up for it
this episode is sponsored by holskin
holskin is a young team in Austria
seeking to make high quality jewelry
from natural products their products are
unique due to the natural elements in
their grains and marbling and they're
great gift for yourself or loved ones
you got some real Swanky looking glasses
right there Connor and I finally got
another bracelet to match my drip on
both arms guys and look at this watch
Joey look at this watch what do you got
there they even do wooden purses the
most insane looking thing ever and
that's one of the coolest persons
exactly yeah Oscar has sustainable
packaging and partners with Charities at
the Jane Goodall Institute and various
reforestation projects plus if you're in
a hurry don't worry holskone will send
out your gifts between two to five days
plus they have free shipping to the US
and most of Europe honestly guys
sometimes I'm just looking for Unique
stuff to show off and wear and wooden
stuff is just the way to go this is the
future and also the seventh birthday of
horse gun is going on right now so guys
happy birthday get yourself some
sustainable and natural drip today make
sure to use our coupon code taste 15 at
checkout to get 15 off your order plus a
free polishing cloth worth 15 euros to
get a whole screen for sponsoring this
episode this episode is sponsored by
Harrys as you guys know we all have
beards on our faces and it is the
perfect way to make us ourselves look
sophisticated and gentleman and proper
so what is the best way in order to keep
up this look why using something
professional like Harry's for instance
because they'll deliver razors right to
your door with refills when you need
them and you won't have to replace your
blade very often they're a sharp on the
eighth shave as they are on the first to
the thing Connor you guys already know
this I've said this a million times I
only use Harry's and I have done for the
past like two years because they are the
best races I've ever used talk to them
well Connor you'll be glad to know then
that you can get the Truman shave trial
set with a 15 value for just three
dollars just three dollars but only if
you go to harrys.com trash Joey Does it
include the five blade German engineered
Razer weighted handle foaming shave gel
and a travel cover you
you God damn so upgrade to a Razer and
skincare routine that will have you
looking your best with Harry's get a 15
trim and shave trial set for just three
dollars by going to harrys.com trash
taste that's harrys.com trash taste for
a three dollar trial set back to the
video I just got like sick from the
Airbnb right oh yeah he got like a
fungal infection yeah he thinks he got
it from the Airbnb it could be a fungal
infection yeah like where I think from
the sheets
it was it was a very old house very
traditional Japanese house just in the
middle of nowhere oh yeah I remember I
remember dad is telling me about that
and you had issues finding a proper
doctor yeah this happens a lot though
every dermatologist he went to was like
damn
I don't know what that is
like we I just had a similar [__]
experience with Sydney actually uh
because one day uh Sydney just had like
a massive like a massive massive bruise
on her leg right it was uh it was that
night we went out
yeah she's fine she's fine it's okay so
my biggest worry was that it was a blood
clot or internal bleeding or something
because like she had not like hit like
that part of her body at all we're just
the bruise just appeared
um and so we're like rushing to try and
find a doctor and I don't know if this
is a Japanese thing but it's just is
there just like a general practitioner
that you can go to like a general okay
store clinics right yeah there's clinics
that specialize in certain parts of the
body and you need to just know this
problem is this particular Clinic yeah
yeah yeah so nice so I'm like what
doctor do I go to because you can't just
go to a general practitioner who can
refer you to the specialist right you
have to go to the specialist
unfortunately I ain't a [__] doctor
so I'm I'm just I'm we were just like
kind of guessing so uh we uh tried we
tried flow uh we tried going to a bone
doctor right and uh because they kind of
like have some specialized
the bone doctor I know I know there's a
word for it but like Orthopedics or the
author something something author
something author something I don't know
uh and you know they uh they looked at
the bruise and they were like that's bad
that looks bad let's do some checks and
they said they did some checks
um and then they uh did like an
ultrasound of it and everything and they
were like yeah we can confirm that it is
not a blood clot or internal bleeding
but we don't know what it is and we were
like can you refer us to somewhere where
we can get like a check to maybe try and
find out what this is and they were like
don't know and I was like
Okay so I've just I've just discovered
like from going to the the doctors for
like certain small things where it's
just like if you don't know what it is
yeah immediately or you don't know the
particular Clinic like if you have like
an ear infection right for example which
I I had a couple of years ago then that
you can just go to an ear eye and throat
specialist right yeah you can usually
get it fixed up but if it's something
like really like open-ended like like an
unknown bruise yeah you're better to
just go to like a general like big
hospital really really because if you go
to a big hospital then they have
everything for the most part whereas
small clinics usually only specialize in
like certain possible bodies and you
have less equipment so if you just go to
a big a big hospital then immediately
you know they'll be like all right so
what's the issue okay well then go visit
this clinic in this building yeah what
you ended up doing so I guess second
part of the story next day we're all
like I'm still really worried about this
massive bruise and then like another one
had appeared the day after as well um
so we were like let's let's just go to
like a much bigger Clinic uh Hospital uh
so we so we went to one and you know
they had a reception and they asked oh
who do you want to see
um and so the doctor
we we were like we want to see a doctor
and uh they were like okay what's the
issue and then you know we explained the
bruise we showed them pictures
um and they were like I don't know if
you should see the dermatologist or like
the bone doctor again and and I was and
I was like unfortunately I'm not a
medical professional just try one I'm
gonna figure it out yeah yeah just go
from there yeah yeah so so they were
like so I was like okay we explained the
symptoms more uh concretely and uh then
uh we also got told that okay if you
have like further issues then they can
maybe refer you to like another
department or something like that
um so they were like let's start you off
in the bone doctor first because
[Music]
because they can do more
um they can do more checks than what we
had in the other thing yeah yeah for
sure
um and so we we queue up uh and it's uh
it's a three hour wait
it is it is uh it is it is a three-hour
wait all right to uh and we're like
don't worry Sydney we're in a hospital
we're gonna we're gonna get the more
we're gonna get the checks that we need
don't worry about it City don't worry
about it Sydney
um so a weird thing so this this end up
being a like a church hospital or
something like that because there were
like sisters in the place like kind of
like nuns working in the place
where the [__] hospital did you go to
this kind of hospitals
it's gonna do a video on it next time
um so after after this like three hour
long Waits uh we she goes in to see the
doctor and then uh she explains her
symptoms and the doctor's like okay I
can't check it right now and she was
like why can't I check it well uh and he
explains well this this is like a
special hospital and we have to be very
polite
um so you know since since you're since
you're since you're a girl we're gonna
get one of like the sisters to
bro I think you went to the wrong
Hospital
I want to go to this hospital just to
see what the [__] up yeah so so
basically so basically she had to go to
another room where like the nurses would
cover up her entire body except for like
that one except for that one area so I I
had no idea like church hospitals were a
thing but like this this was like this
is like a weird experience for me as
well
um
so that happened and then the doctor
looks at it and he just goes I don't
know what it is let's have an x-ray and
I was like why why are we uh why are we
doing an x-ray for a bruise maybe it's
something I don't understand I I don't
understand
um and so so we do the X-ray wait
another like half an hour 45 minutes for
this for this x-ray sure uh at this
point we've been in the hospital for
about four hours
uh and so uh we they do they do the
X-ray wait for the results go back in
and they were like yeah we don't know
what it is uh do you want to try that
do you want to try the dermatologist and
I was like how long is the wait for that
and he was like it's the same process as
uh the process for this department and I
was just like Cindy how do you feel
right now is this is this
life-threatening like what did you say
how do you feel to somebody like please
tell me you're fine
ever get started
it's uh we we never found out what it
was is it still there it's it's healing
right now uh so my rule of advice go to
an actual Hospital next time maybe don't
go to whatever the [__] this church
hospital is yeah I mean we uh it's a
part of part of the issue was we tried
to find we tried to find like an
English-speaking Hospital right uh so
that was like the closest one to our
vicinity that luckily Geeks plus had
found for us
um so it was it was it was a proper
hospital just just just he also signed
up to Scientology
oh that's cool yeah were they just like
using a big stop and a video idea yeah
so two for one so in the so in the end
uh luckily Sydney has a local doctor in
the US and she sent a picture and she
was like oh you probably have a low
platelet count and I was like damn
that's uh that that took uh how long not
to like [__] on all of Japan because I
don't think I do that enough yeah I've
heard a lot of horror stories about like
hospitals and doctors and stuff here and
I've I've just had generally just meh
experience I mean it's better than the
UK because I can at least see someone
here which there's someone on the same
day yeah uh I remember when I when I
filmed the uh uh when I [__] up my
knee on the uh special the oh oh yeah
yeah I went to a a leg Clinic that
specialized in it was mainly elderly
people there and I was yeah I was like
the only person who's like under 80
there and um now that you mention it I
had this weird memory where they made me
they wanted to scan my leg and they
wanted me to take my pants off and they
gave me like these shitty gym shorts and
I went in this room that was clearly a
used to be a pedian a pediatrician
office because it had just like
cute little lion things all around the
wall like some of like a horror movie
like the stereotypical kid hospital room
yeah yeah we're sitting there with these
weird ass old shorts and I'm like this
is weird and I just got to go on the
thing and they they propped my leg up
not with like some kind of no not that
it needs to be anything it's amazing but
it was something like a can of something
that's how they propped my leg up to
take the X-ray I was like it's like a
can of peaches or something like what
the [__] is this where am I where am I
getting scammed is this like perks of
knowing Japanese because I've had the
most normal hospital experiences I
probably also had um I went to uh an
English-speaking doctor and I I go there
and we rock up and uh obviously he knows
it's in English actually I did the
appointment like it was all it was all
English yeah I rock up and I go in and
uh he sits there and he's like uh what
is uh wrong and I go
oh um I think my throat hurts and he
goes
throat throat nanny
I was like what
was it no no no no sorry no door it's
like no door I was like man this man
doesn't know what throat is in English
I'm [__] I'm [__]
he's a doctor and he did he was
especially in English was what is wrong
and after that yeah and he's like yeah
what I knew when he said what is wrong I
was like oh no oh no and then he didn't
know what throat was in English and I
was like I'm [__]
what are you gonna tell me exactly yeah
so it was just kind of like really
painful I hope I said everything correct
and I hope he got it it turned into a
Japanese one because I put more Japanese
than he spoke English I was like oh [__]
Jesus Christ yeah yeah so it's funny
like most countries I've been to it's
like a different Healthcare experience
you know uh you know in America you got
to mortgage your second house yeah to go
to the hospital but you get it uh in
England uh you gotta wait till next
Century to get a appointment that's for
free and in Japan you kind of play Dr
Bingo where you self-diagnose yourself
and hope you go to the right I can't
believe Japan got your fight
[Laughter]
yo you speak English and you can get me
fixed up that's a double like basically
if you get if you get sick in Japan hope
to God that it's something that you can
self-diagnose yourself trying to pay the
wedding in Japan you can definitely pay
for better quality and faster service
and stuff hey how much have you wailed
on doctors
yeah I've completed this entire area bro
seen them all because mailing
recommended uh this uh an English
dentist and I started asking around I
realized almost every Foreigner I know
goes to an American dentist yeah yeah or
American training is that like that I
trust the Japanese dentists dude
Japanese dances are scary I've heard I
heard they stay because obviously the
way you train is very important yeah uh
and you know obviously we're from the UK
we get we get memed a lot for uh having
bed yeah yeah yeah the joke Everly I
know you love your British jokes but
American dancers know what's up I'll
give them credit yeah they have the best
[__] teeth like they do they do yeah
they do too good because they floss yeah
yeah you can go to a lot of yeah you can
go a lot of English speaking in American
it might be a Japanese dentist but it'll
be like American trained and American
practice right yeah it's very common
it's a lot of them how many
dermatologists did you guys have to go
through and I I never knew how that
situation got solved did you ever find
out what it was never came to a
satisfactory conclusion I think did I
just gave but when the last
dermatologist he went to was like I
think you should see a real doctor and
he's like you're a dermatologist
this is a scam yeah I just took the
photo for my Personal Collection yeah I
think he just I think when we went back
to the States for Christmas he went to
see like a doctor that was that was that
was the happy ending going back to the
States and now I'm like if I ever have
like a medical emergency am I just gonna
have to book an overnight flight to the
states if it's like if you don't if you
don't know what it is because like yeah
it seems like similar experience where
the doctor just told me um you should
probably see as Doctor is that
specializes in that and they don't refer
you to to a doctor that specializes or
just have like a Japanese friend who can
take you to an actual proper hospital
and where you can talk to an actual
Japanese doctor Japanese doctors are
like damn that's crazy
you know when you go to the doctor and
they think it like they probably know
what the problem is I can't remember if
they did this in the UK because I um do
they tell you like what it like the
worst case scenarios of what it could be
as well or do they just kind of wait
until you've gone through all the
normals like stuff and solutions
I feel like that's the fastest way to
freak someone out yeah yeah so I I uh
after the cycling thing that I did right
like it was like eight days of cycling I
had this like pimple that was like so
painful on my ass
I'm sorry no go ahead no it's fine it's
funny it's so funny it's so painful it
could be cancer
you might have asked him yeah so so like
uh and it didn't go away for like a
while and I just kind of like it would
it would hurt for a week and then it
wouldn't it would just go and then it
would come back and hurt for a week and
this just kind of happened and it was
like I was [__] stupid because every
week it went I just totally forgot about
it and then I came back I'm like ah yeah
I guess that it still hurts huh all
right so after like two three months of
this I was like all right I guess I
should go and check it out and so I go
to the doctor also really [__]
awkward that I should be like he's like
what's the problem I'm like all right
well this
he's like do you exercise I'm like wow
nine days actually yeah that's the
problem too healthy uh and uh he's he
looks at he goes oh yeah it's pretty
just a uh you know an anti-market
antibacterial thing or whatever
infection yeah it just takes some bad
eggs and you'll be fine and I was like
oh cool he's like but it could be herpes
and I was like what I was like why would
you tell me that because I think after
that but it could be your face I'm like
what the [__] how would I even get it on
my ass what the [__] you have asses
trust me I'm a doctor
nowhere he was like it's it's dude it's
totally this just take this use this
cream it'll be good and then he goes low
chance though I hope he's for real
what the [__] like why would you put
that in my head yeah why would you tell
me that because I took the antibiotics
and I thought oh my God this isn't get
rid of it I [__] Ash herpes
uh but yeah no it's all good and then I
took it all gone then I feel like you're
a [__] idiot for three months and I
was like that'll go
take this thing for a week and I could
avoid this pain I'd be streaming man
like reposition because I'm like all
right I gotta go on the left cheek now
pimple's starting to hurt damn I wish at
least you didn't get out yeah at least
you can at least I don't have ass herpes
so that's thank you
if it didn't disappear for a week if you
like sweating you're like how the [__]
did I get that
this must have been from the answer
ain't no way
yeah also when you were growing up right
did you ever because I don't know if
you'd go to did you ever go to swimming
pools a lot like America or did you do
this a lot in the summertime dude I
don't know like did you ever have to
they tell you man be careful about like
verrucas oh
I wonder if it's got an American name
because that sounds so British I feel
like that's painfully what is it called
wait what is it Veruca it's like an
ingrown wart kind of thing yeah American
war for Veruca uh plantart what plantar
wart I've never heard of that
um I've never heard of that uh it's like
you would um you'd have to be careful I
guess maybe it's a kid like only for
kids uh it's not only for kids yeah it's
like you have to be careful going in the
pool if you had one and they would be
like kids if you have one don't come in
uh the pool uh and it was basically like
you could get it by just walking on the
same ground as somebody else who has it
like Barefoot so it's like a wart you
get on your foot or yeah I'll show you
yeah it's it's kind of like a wart that
grows into the skin
um okay yes yes I I don't think we use
the same word for yes yeah yeah okay
we don't have the same word for it yeah
like a hole yeah it is actually kind of
like because I had a Veruca for years
and I did not know how to remove it
right
um so there's a lot of like different
methods I know what you're gonna say
well I feel like okay I thought you were
gonna because you can freeze it off yeah
no no yeah you can freeze it off which
is what I tried doing
um no no like there is there is
literally a device you can buy in
England which yeah which is kind of like
a freeze dry and you freeze the warts
for all like a certain amount of time a
day you like uh scrape it off yeah yeah
and then you like continue yeah yeah
yeah yeah you continue doing that
um
parmigiano so you want some parmigiano
yeah so I tried doing that for like what
felt like months and it just did not go
away I don't know why it didn't work
maybe I was doing it wrong
um and then I realized it might be
herpes
so then I just go [__] time side of
like putting either like
I tried freezing it and then went to a
doctor and then he gave me like acid
that you can put on it which you put on
it like you apply a little bit every day
a layer gets like a leg [__] yeah it's
like Breaking Bad a layer gets peeled
off every day yeah
um that didn't work uh so in the end I
just cut the foot off I just I I just
was just it was like a episode from like
alien or something I just [__] got a
got a [__] knife and just like get
out of here you carved it out I [__]
carved out oh my god um never got a
Veruca since it worked [__] yeah do not
do this dude this is not this is not
medical advice yeah obviously but it
totally [__] worked for me I just
find a weird how we don't talk about
that anymore and they never get brought
up and this is the first time I've ever
heard about like yeah why is this like
the thing that I was talking about it's
huge and then we just don't talk about
it and then you know the worst thing
Sydney uh Cindy had a Veruca problem as
well like a few years ago tried the same
things I did didn't work as well it
would always like what happened is when
you walked into the kitchen
unironically I know Ron I didn't I
didn't tell her to do it I just said
this works like let's not do that
because let's do what what the doctor
said yeah tried the acid thing tried the
freeze-dry thing what would happen is
that it would get to a point where the
Veruca is really small but you would
never be able to get rid of it and it
would always no matter what for some
reason grow back right and become bigger
again so one day she just after months
of trying to trying to deal with it she
she did the [__] knife scissor method
and just stabbed it out and uh yeah it's
it's it's it's gone now
um yeah
[__] painful yeah you're literally
stabbing yourself I'll be honest I'll be
honest
just something about the feeling of like
feeding that little [__] that's been
stuck stuck in your life you know the
movies are still getting shot and
they're getting the bullet out with the
knife yeah
[Music]
yeah it's painful but yeah satisfying to
get it out yeah I wonder how that's not
a problem in onsens or anything because
everyone bathes before they go in yeah
but I don't think that's how I don't
think that matters yeah I think it's
like a viral thing actually oh yeah yeah
I'm never gonna step in a public pool
ever again
[__] public pools anyway huh no you
don't go in public pools
are you go to the public pool that's
true it's probably because also all the
kids are just pissing in the pool right
I mean that probably doesn't help let's
be real wait
I've always wondered you know you know
when they say you get stung by a
jellyfish and you piss on that yeah is
that like an urban myth no I've done it
I'm pretty sure they they tested this on
like some show maybe Mythbusters they
test this and it was like negligible
yeah it was like really I think
Australia
I think what you're supposed to do is
like put vinegar some kind of like base
on it to like level out the like because
it's it's basically like acidic
essentially it's like yeah if you
accidentally poured acid on yourself
yeah so what you you should do is like
you pour some kind of bass which is like
maybe vinegar or like some other base
but like who's going to the beach with a
[__] bottle of vinegar it's [__] up
the Australians Australians clearly so
it's just like at this point it's just
like please just put anything on it to
stop the burning and it's like oh I
don't have any water
I've had to piss on my friend's leg
out of context Cliffs
so was there a jellyfish involved I want
to know before yes
on each other yeah well I got a cool
down have you ever has any of you ever
been stung by a jellyfish before never
I've never even said what does it feel
like yeah I've been stung by a bee no
I'm so jealous oh I haven't been stung
by bee I've been stung by a jellyfish
many times
it's [__] horrible what does it feel
like so I've been stung by a you know
the blue bottle jellyfish you see quite
often they're [__] everywhere in
Australia
um yeah it is good coffee
um but yeah I had one where it was like
wrapped around my arm like that like the
whole way like when I was a kid yeah um
and it literally just feels like someone
is taking like a metal rod like a hot
metal rod and it's just doing this
you know they are they are yeah well
only some jellyfish yeah they they just
like split and they make new versions
they're just doing their thing not when
it's wrapped around your [__] I don't
think jellyfish are cute yeah I think
jellyfish are cute they're cute [__] no
man like my thalassophobia gets 10 times
worse when you see a group of jellyfish
holy [__] man no get the jellyfish out
of here you rather be stuck deep in the
ocean or in a cave
cave the Cave's not underwater is it
could be a underwater cave oh that's
just like two nightmares yeah
or stuck in the ocean but I can't
breathe in the ocean let's say there's
some way we can we can you can breathe
in the depths of the ocean
okay okay would you rather be stuck in
the middle of the ocean on like a float
or something yeah
um for like 24 hours or would you rather
be stuck in a cave for 24 hours oh cave
100 cave yeah 100 way easier though
because of the float one you can kind of
just chill out just jump chill I would
not be chilling bro yeah I would be
freaking the [__] out yeah they're both
pretty easy
oh that's just survival at this point
right yeah yeah it's in a cave I can
like pick a corner and just sleep but
like where am I gonna sleep in the ocean
can you sleep on the barge it won't be
comfy oh on a cave wood coffee I don't
think we're concerned about the
comfiness of a cake wait which one would
you pick uh uh depends I mean because
like there's a lot of variables like
okay this is scary man it's not a scary
shows the ocean ocean 24 hours is Chill
on a barge it's fine that's Conor's next
video by the way I spent 24 hours on a
bar
[__] down you should [__] chill out
you don't know what you do not know
what's down there with a cake with the
boats they don't touch the bar with a
cave you can see it coming
could be trapped in you know you could
be it's dark it's gross you can't see
anything
um you can't see anything on the water
like you you don't know what's floating
on the top right just like floating on
the top yeah that's fine but because
fish don't they don't give a [__] about
trying to hit official at least on my
concerns yeah
because it doesn't it doesn't taste like
anything they don't there's no meaning
for them to try and attack you you'll be
fine unlike a little boat no I'm sure
you'll be fine tonight either it's just
a matter of like which one am I more
mentally mentally yeah mentally
comfortable no hell no I like the ocean
but hell no like the more I've grown
older the more I realize I definitely
have like thalassophobia really like
yeah just did you have it as a kid or
I've always hated the sea I guess you
know what my dad used to do to teach me
how to swim oh God
okay okay okay I was like seven or
something or six we'd go to the beach
he'd pick me up and just like throw me
into the like deep end of the ocean it's
like all right swim honey
that's what Lions do today it's like he
didn't even like try and teach you
technique he's just not throws you my
dad's not a very good teacher you know
the way he tried teaching me how to read
the time was he'd point at the clock and
go what time is it
and if I couldn't answer he'd get really
mad that is like the most Asian thing
I've ever heard in my life like the
worst
you should have seen him when he was
trying to teach me how to drive oh God
how was that
um he ended up not being the one to
teach me how to drive that's for sure
Jesus yeah unfortunately fortunately I
hate to call my dad out but he's also
like not the best teacher either because
I remember having a similar experience
uh when my dad tried to teach me how to
ride a bike
way it was kind of like the teaching met
was son you do this and I yeah yeah you
know you do this it's simple and I was
like Dad what's the technique he's like
just do it just do it she didn't know
it's like and obviously I fall off and
he's like you're doing it wrong it's
like what am I doing wrong
keep doing it just keep just keep doing
it right
like a trial by fire kind of like
teaching method yeah just just do the
thing but harder and better this is the
get good man yeah it literally that's
just the Asian method there is like no
Fidelity to teaching to make techniques
the technique is just get good and you
keep trying until you get good yeah
pretty much yeah the way they teach math
is what's four times four
wrong do it again yeah how about how
what is it
Jesus is very strange the biggest
anomaly is that Asians are good at math
it's like how does that happen it's like
it's not drown
no I didn't drown how
because she got good
so like you would just drown
I think I would just like flail around
and he'd just pick me up and then do it
again
[Music]
I I don't like the ocean it's like one
inch from drowning it's like all right
dunking you yeah so I like pools I like
swimming I just don't like doing it in
the sea in the ocean you don't like it
when you can't see the bottom right oh
I've yeah yeah
as soon as we get to that point I'm like
get me the [__] out of here or like the
idea of like rip currents yeah like what
you just get pulled in there's nothing
stopping yeah that's so [__]
terrifying scary man I love the ocean
have you ever been swimming and then you
felt something like a fish or like
seaweed it didn't feel something
most likely though it was seaweed yeah
oh yeah okay okay yeah I felt that and I
I just you know every time I just feel
like I'm just a little like flicker or
something I [__] I'm like my pants I
literally like shits himself I'm like
get me the [__] out yeah yeah I don't
know it just something about the ocean
terrifies me about boats you like being
on boats I
have boats
huh I like boats I like boats too yeah
because you're safe yeah I love a boat I
don't know I love a good boy love a good
boat it's a British in me I think I love
about it
it's a sailor in me I love boats are
chill uh I don't know I like the ocean
but again yeah I think it's terrifying
how little we know about it yada yada
ever gets it yeah it's good of things
down there yeah that's about it now
caves ocean caves the scariest no cave
diving I'm never that's that [__] is the
worst yeah I watch those YouTube videos
about it I'm like all right that's
that's one thing I'm never gonna do yeah
I watch those kind of YouTube videos
just to get I don't know why it's like a
morbid curiosity you know yeah yeah I
think the thing that makes it so
terrifying is that if you dive in the
ocean and you're you know you're
exploring these caves like if something
goes wrong you can't come back up yeah
then they can't retrieve you yeah yeah
because you have to decompress for like
like an hour yeah if you go down it's 50
meters it's something like you have to
wait like an hour yeah and then come
back up it's like like what if you run
out of air yeah
it's terrifying it's like caving is
already scary why are you adding the
element of like like hard mode yeah and
cold and you can't see anything yeah I
do Wonder okay I have noticed a pattern
with a lot of people who have moved to
Japan I wonder if you followed that
pattern oh no have you stopped being a
weeb have you have you stopped watching
anime or oh of course you bring no
actually I've watched more anime oh
really oh you're the one oh wait wait do
people usually stop once we move here
well I mean like I feel yeah because I
know what God's talking about it's like
you know when you're visiting Japan it's
like all right oh yeah bro I'm going
there every [__] day you know buying
anime figures you know reading manga
watch anime blah blah blah and then
after like six months to a year I'd say
you're just like
maybe got our camera once a year yeah
because because I was wondering these
this Anime Cafe I'm gonna call it a
phase is it is it a phase
is it a face style it's a lifestyle was
that purely for Content or just do you
genuinely just love anime
but I'm like may as well make a video
about it if I'm going at this minute of
course especially since they're so
expensive but yeah I will watching more
anime isn't necessarily a result of me
have moving to Japan more like a result
of me living with Titus oh okay okay
yeah okay so he is the biggest Weeble
yeah
I've been watching a lot more anime
what about you guys I don't like
watching stuff by myself I love it
really no I actually prefer watching it
by myself yeah yeah really no I I
usually like having another person like
to experience it I feel like that just
Nerfs the experience for me because I'm
like now I have to tailor my watching
schedule around another person as well
and then what happens is that we were
like honey we should watch this one show
we watched like two episodes where
someone of us gets a bit tired I wanna
like one of us might want to continue
watching but no we've got to stop for
the other person and then we're like
we'll watch it when we are next
available and then we just never finish
it so that's that's why that's that's
why I'm just like I'd rather watch by
myself but you seem to watch a lot more
anime with dietist than uh we're able to
right yeah there's some shows that I
have been watching solo but I feel like
from most of the ones I've watched It's
usually with him right if I don't think
he hasn't watched it yet all right
recently uh we finished watching Butchy
The Rock
hell yeah hell yeah so there I I just I
love a good cute girls doing cute things
show yeah why are you shake it's so good
so good I'm halfway through it I I hate
that I love it yeah sure comment on our
on our um we spoke about watching The
Rock and someone commented saying
something like Conor is everything that
Bocce has an irrational fear of
because she has social anxiety and she's
afraid of meeting people like you
probably
she'd probably crumble under her own
pressure interacting with someone like
you oh no do you still watch a lot of
Shoujo as well oh my God recently I've
been watching uh Jonah of the Dawn oh
why what what is this reaction
that's so good there's there's been one
of the best yeah oh my God Hawk
oh yeah I saw you Tweeting about it and
I'm just like oh she's on that side now
I actually did want to watch it but then
I found out that it just like abruptly
ends and doesn't have a season two well
that's why you read the Manga after yeah
you continue with the manga a boy
I saw I saw an anime recently and I was
like this has the most Emily Aesthetics
which one sugar apple or fairies
actually okay of course
oh [__] God I started watching sugar
apple fairy tale as well is this a like
recent one yeah yeah it's this season
not this season it's very pretty
if you put like strawberries into an
aesthetic it would be this show
and there's fairies yeah
Shame about the slavery in the show
I was just like I was just like this is
a really really cute show explain the
plot why is this slavery because so
humans have ins in this world humans
have enslaved fairies yeah okay okay yes
anime obsessed with the slaves I don't
know
it is but the romance aspect is a little
weird because it's like she buys a slime
like a fairy it's like a fully grown
like dude by the way it's it's like the
they're not called they're called a
worker
guys guys guys they're not they're not
slaves
their work of fairies okay but uh that
you can buy as a profiter workers
they're working yeah
about the anime yeah
just start watching it because it's just
like eagles slavery kind of thing yeah
like you know in like every Easter guys
like the guy buying like the slave but
like they're not like other slave owners
they're gonna treat the slavery nicely
yeah yeah yeah so she needs him to
escort her because she's trying to go to
like a confectionary Fair like
competition thing so question is this a
wholesome show yeah kind of no there's
like blood and stuff
because the title sounds like you know
something like really like sugar apple
you know cutesy and bubbly She's Like a
Warrior yeah she's going to a
confectionary fat and then she's just he
is so hot by the way the warrior fairy
yeah but yeah I'm not a big fan of like
the romance Dynamic at the beginning
well of course I mean she technically
oats
he obviously like he distrusts humans
and doesn't like them for obvious
reasons right but he still like does
that weird thing where he's like teasing
her and like yeah yeah well I mean why
is this the genre yeah yeah but it's
like you have to ease into that stuff
you can't roll that out episode one you
can't oh he does that [__] episode one
episode one like like minute 12.
like why is this so sudden in episode
one there's there's this line that uh
there's a lot of yattas so they're like
this is you know after he purchases him
and they're in a carriage going home
together and she's like oh I've never
had my first kiss before and he goes
what are you a child I looked up her age
and she's 15 years and I was just like
yes she is a child yeah
like he's just like it's weird because
you're You're Expecting there to be a
dynamic of like they're bickering and
like he doesn't like her yeah but at the
same time they're also trying to cram in
this Dynamic of like oh he's flirty with
her yeah and it's like it's just this
isn't working yeah that's that's a bit
weird yeah I was wondering what your
opinion was because like you know the
aesthetic is like your aesthetic down to
the T I feel for sure but beautiful show
looks like it's gonna pass on this
yeah I don't think you'd like it but
it's just I have to keep watching okay
but episode one I was like I'm not
really sold on this very much like the
designs are gorgeous but like I don't
know I don't know he reminded me of like
he gave me the same ick as like usui
from kaichua maidsama oh okay huh my
king he gave me the same ick yeah yeah
oh can you relax like stop it you're
being weird at least with Kaicho made
someone he wasn't a slave well yeah but
he was still weird
so actually the reason why I started
watching Yono the dawn is I had already
planned on watching it because everyone
was like this is such a you show why
haven't you watched it yet yeah okay I
should and
uh while we were watching the first
episode of sugar apple fairy tale Titus
was like you know what did this from
romance Dynamic way better and I'm like
what and he's like yelling of the Dawn
you should watch it yeah well you know
they're doing I feel like he's one of
the goats it's sharks are good and it's
so beautiful I love it so far I've
it's been a while since like I've
watched a show and like episode one my
mouth is like open but I'm like I
watched episode one and two I think I
don't really have any feelings on it
I also uh I'm currently on season two
I'm very behind on everything but I'm
currently on season two of uh Love is
War oh okay okay I love it I I think
season two is when like the last hour of
season two is when it really starts to
show its true colors really because I
loved season one I I was like I didn't
love season one I was like this is
enjoyable and then season two made me
care about the characters because they
actually like get characters I can't
it's one of those shows where like I
can't watch it without grinning yeah
every episode it's because it's like
it's genuinely fun yeah because we wear
this we had this conversation in
previous podcasts about how we're
getting like a little bit tired of like
romance anime and manga what do you
think makes a good romance like Dynamic
well what like what like draws you to a
romance time Dynamic okay well a good
rom-com has to be funny funny and like
sort of unpredictable yeah a good
romance
I've noticed that the romance anime that
I'm most drawn to is very gradual like
well I feel like it has to right because
otherwise then it becomes unrealistic
you know if if the romance happens too
fast then it's like that's that doesn't
happen in real life yeah in real life
we're like dude
my love story it happens pretty quickly
but it's so like
super cute I guess but they they still I
feel like in my love story they still
you know like like the start is fast but
then like actually them developing is a
long process you know oh my God whereas
like I've seen some romance anime where
it's like you know episode one they meet
and then by episode three they're like
[__] and I'm like oh chill bro like
what where's the build up yeah
you know so it's like I feel even if
like the start is fast like in my love
story like if if the progression is like
slow yeah then it's like oh it's more
realistic so you get more attached to
the characters yeah right whereas like
from this [__] sugar apple show I
feel like immediately it's already like
yeah yeah
it kind of yeah I like it you know it's
the best when like you can really sense
their individual personalities yeah and
you enjoy watching them on screen even
if it's just them like by themselves
yeah I mean it was kind of refreshing
for me to see just to see more modern
Shoujo anime being made that's not like
a rehash of a very old franchise or
something because I feel like Shojo
anime are just getting way way more
unpopular now or like less is less is
being met it's not yeah less is just
being made in the modern day I think
good
excuse you
yeah no I agree because there's so many
good shows and rip-offs
okay so as the anime May Cafe expert now
sure you've been to more than like all
of us combined you around 27. okay yeah
definitely okay what is what has been
like your best experience
your Cafe I went with family on that it
was actually amazing it was actually the
dog [__] one you told me to the terrible
one which Banana Fish yeah you liked the
pasta the pasta yeah the pasta was okay
but it was just all [__] oh I mean yeah
yeah they charged like like a [__]
thirty dollars a cookie yeah but that's
Anime Cafe yeah it was like they barely
themed it they put up a bunch of
wallpaper and called it a day oh yeah
and they got a reserve you're gonna
reserve for this
[__] off dude that's what pisses me off
is that I have to reserve to go to
something that's mid and I'm like no no
don't no no you don't get to remember no
you'll go for like
the Instagram moment you know no that's
kind of all it's for in the room if
you're a true fan
I am gonna if I if I swear to God if I
have to buy clear files I'm I'm not oh
no no no no no no no that's an immediate
skills
at a place yeah I know I'm sorry I mean
that had plates and cups and stuff like
that yeah I'll take you to better ones
maybe okay okay let's go to a better one
next time it's almost so cute because
like the merch they actually like put
effort into it so it's just good yeah no
it did what I maybe I've been it it gave
me what I've been wanting from an anime
collab Cafe where right every menu item
you could look at it and you could
pinpoint exactly what they're
referencing yeah from the manga or the
show yeah like it's I was like oh that's
the scene where you go drop some Curry
yeah that's the scene with the meals
hair cubes that's the scene with like
you could yeah it was really
an episode where like uh Yuko asked for
yaksoba and then they get the order but
it's yakisaba which is like the fried
fish right so I ordered the yaksoba and
she was like okay so who ordered the yak
soba and I was like I did and they
brought out this like [__] plastic
container like this white plastic
container and I opened it up and it was
a fried fish
and then five minutes later she came
back with the actual
like that's brilliant that's [__]
five head man I trolled at the [__]
Cafe but it's like it's actually unique
and like fun and imagine someone hadn't
seen nichijou and they were like uh
wrong excuse me excuse me I thought it
was troll when I gave us the food in our
Cafe I was like
okay so Joey got the premium experience
the premium experience have you been to
a JoJo Cafe uh
that's tight that's that's high yeah
it's probably it's probably why it's
good
bro yeah oh yeah um they're only uh fake
cafes coming out give me up I've
surprisingly knocked bro free fans don't
leave the house what do you mean
fate fences stop playing at the time
they would have to log off and go and
real I thought we'd lose money
all you need to do is be like be just
like Pokemon go it you know like oh you
come to this one physical Place yeah one
free pool yo there's a line that
stretches from like here to Kyoto man
like [__] it up I'll let you know if I
see a fake all right okay so you've
talked all about cafes thank you what is
one thing that maybe you know you kind
of hated about Japan after the fact that
recently you became to dislike a lot so
it's not necessarily like something I
dislike about Japan it's just there's
now I uh after moving here and like
making content here
I have now exposed to a new genre of
annoying ass YouTube comments
I feel like you guys have talked about
this already but now that I have to deal
with it I'm going to complain about it
yeah okay so hey you have two two sides
of the spectrum all right yeah on one
side you have the Japan dick riders yeah
who get really mad at you if you dare
say anything even a little bit negative
yeah oh that's all I ever [__] do
yeah oh it's like fresh taste go ahead
so just like in one of my what is it
like they it's so annoying and one of my
themed Cafe videos I got a comment there
was actually a few that were like this
that were like
typical Western girl
hates that Japan won't cater to to her
taste buds because I said that the
burgers that they or on Cafe were [__]
yeah yeah
this isn't a cultural issue they were
just bad food like it's the type of
commenter who is like
how dare you like say anything they
assume that like whatever you eat in
Japan it is god-like yeah yeah they they
treat Japan as like a Utopia they can't
do wrong right yeah you cannot and
there's some good burger joints but yeah
yeah and then on the uh similarly on the
other annoying side of the spectrum you
have the Japan haters yeah who no matter
what you say like if you say anything
even a little positive they they have to
come in and like rain on your parade
yeah like they'll be like hey I went to
this room
birthday and I had a really good time
and then someone will come and be like
have fun getting sexually assaulted on
the train yeah but I'm like dude
it's always the most like they they
clearly like can't take the particular
situation you're in and yeah negative
about that situation so they have to
bring some kind of wild tangent right
like you could be doing like oh here I
am at a at a 7-Eleven let's try all the
sandwiches and then one of the comments
would be like yeah but do you know what
the Japanese did during World War II was
that absolutely horrible and I'm like
what does that have to do with anything
Jerry's grandma just told about that
yeah
we've got a first-hand account yeah
exactly it's like it's like I can't
obviously like you can't please
everybody of course I mean there's
there's been so much Japan praise online
for a very very long time there's a lot
of pushback to it and it makes us weird
and then there's people who are very
protective of it like you said it's just
a whole weird thing it's very weird when
it's very fun to hear Japanese is
people's opinion when you talk to them I
went to the bar uh like two nights ago
um and uh the guy asked us to move up
because more customers coming because
it's small rights yeah move up and then
there's a Japanese guy and there's two
of them they're absolutely smashed and
he goes he tries to grab my hand I'm
like all right and he was like you like
Japan I was like yeah Japan's pretty
good uh he starts going off about
how he feels about Japan right Japanese
guy
he goes everyone in Japan is hentai and
I was like all right he's like everyone
is hentai and I was like all right okay
he gets this guy right here pointing at
the bar guy this guy's biggest hentai I
know it's just a normal bar working guys
don't know each other I was like all
right all right he kept saying it louder
and louder this guy right here this guy
this particular guy is a pervert the
biggest pervert in Japan and he keeps
going off I'm just like I'm like that
all right okay dude all right all right
the bomb man comes over like hey dude
could you please shut the [__] up
there's other customers please [__]
stop and he's like no you're a [__]
answer
man you're like please please please
start his friend's like dude dude I was
like
what the [__] Jesus uh yeah that was uh
that was my fun experience
yeah I love this place and he was
telling me he's an architect and I was
like what do you think about Japanese
Architects she goes Super [__]
it's like we build and tear down right
away I mean that is true yeah he's like
you know he's like Europe is the gold
standard of architecture I was like oh
cool I was like can't wait to start gun
Jerry then
[__] that no they were they were funny
guys they were great yeah uh but they
were with like a girl who looked
extremely young oh oh yeah they were
like yeah they were like in their 40s
they were like yeah it's a 20 year old
girl with them all right cool
guy is the biggest hentai at least
that's not why they were shouting in the
previous state right now
at least he's self-aware it was a fun
night though yeah
have you got any comments asking like oh
how's your Japanese coming along oh why
are you not why are you not fluent yet
oh all the time you've lived in Japan
for a year and you're not fluent in
Japanese
what's wrong with you
yeah it's been a lot of fun I mean like
you know there aren't like enough
annoying comments for it to truly be an
issue yeah something I've noticed yeah
where it's like it's people who
like expect you to just constantly like
be loving everything yeah or or people
who want you to be having a miserable
time for some reason what I found
fascinating I feel and this isn't every
single comment that's like the the Japan
hating comments but I've noticed a lot
of comments that are like very against
Japan and want you to also have a bad
time uh probably people who once lived
in Japan or spent a while in Japan and
maybe didn't have the best time and
they're like salty yeah and they're
salty that yeah they're seeing you have
a good time it's either like people it's
not every comment obviously oh yeah of
course but like I've noticed that
there's people who will just be salty at
the fact that I live here yeah I think I
think it's also because it's it's um
maybe some commenters or some viewers
they see how how we got here and you
know it's very rare circumstance and I
think it's very lucky yeah I think I
think that also it can annoy people
because they're like that's [__] up
that they get to go and you maybe do
this yeah why can't that be me yeah yeah
yeah I'm not saying it's all of it but I
you know I think there's a lot of
aspects to it yeah and you know we're
very lucky and we get to no no yeah yeah
we get the best of both worlds
underground we don't have to work
in the Japanese company yeah we can we
can still live in Japan and have all the
benefits of that sure sure yeah I feel
like there has been a recent new wave of
how you call it like Japan dick riders
as well oh my gosh just because just
because I've seen like a massive new
trend when YouTube shows and tick tocks
that are just like weak like I I feel
like the you know J vlogging scene we
had like they had like exposed most of
the things you can find in Japan right
now on like the normal day-to-day basis
you know you can't really have an AJ
Vlog oh look at this vending machine
anymore because we all know about the
Japanese vending machines but it feels
like to tick tock they're they're just
discovering this right yeah where you
find you find shorts and you find tick
tocks where it's just like look at this
10 reasons why Japan is living in
in a vending machine I'm like other
countries some of them like like lie
yeah what is that I saw one that was
like people are lining up four hours at
Starbucks for this new drink and I'm
like I can go down the street and get
that drink in like two minutes no one's
lining up four hours way more
starbuckses than are needed in Japan
I don't I don't I hate that people are
just taking like the most mundane things
and trying to be like
isn't this crazy because in Japan yeah
because like you're spawning more like
Japan dick riders yeah exactly and it's
just those crazy Japanese
what's as long as you waited in line for
or anything in Japan oh Cafe two hours
two hours
you are the person waiting in line Emily
uh the bank
the hospital
[Music]
wait okay another one I'm sorry I feel
like I'm complaining too much welcome to
trash day welcome to trash face this
this is this is uh okay okay you know
what other comment that I saw a lot of
at the beginning that I thought was so
like annoying and like patronizing well
when I made the video of like I moved to
Japan you get all the comments that are
like
you know it's not like the animes right
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like oh no no
there's no
there's no [__] I'm not
like
it
would help me along I'm gonna like moved
you think I'm gonna turn my life around
overseas move to this country and you
think me at my big girl age thinks that
I'm about to walk into like my high
school rom-com Shojo dream are you
kidding me yeah I mean it's because it's
because you know they're normally dumb
kids saying that [__] and yeah they're
probably 15 themselves or it's or it's
people who you know because they only
they only see the your videos boom
you're in Japan so for them it's like oh
what the [__] yeah yeah like you mulling
over the decision me telling you 500
times on on call you should come over
here they don't see that they don't see
the Visa person I know but I'm like come
on no I know I know hot take
I think honestly if you've gone through
that like period in your life where you
have been like a massive let's say Japan
dick rider super weebie that's fine man
I think it actually helps you no it does
you know a lot of information okay okay
wait what helps you
um just kind of have like not being
afraid to kind of like do a lot of
people in the west if you're like overly
weebie or something like that it's kind
of cringe right yeah I thought learning
Japan was cringe yeah Japanese sorry
yeah I thought London Japanese was so
like oh you're learning anime that's
yeah [__] I should have learned it and
and I will I will say like now that we
like live in Japan
um we you know communicate with Japanese
people way more often I'm so [__]
jealous of Sydney because she has no
shame at all in like being as like you
know she's been through her weebie phase
yeah that's just Sydney that's just
Sydney but like every time we go like
traveling or anything like that we go
like just different places she has like
no shame at all and like trying to like
what you know do things that in our
minds was like perceived as weebie but
in here in Japan it's like people
[__] love it here because you know
you there's someone that's kind of like
trying to
learn about that culture oh if there's
one thing Japanese people love it's
someone who's not Japanese trying to be
Japanese yeah exactly exactly like oh
they're embracing our culture like
they're trying to you know like
assimilate and like that makes our life
easier
but you know it's like seeing someone
like trying really hard to like yeah you
know uh talk to someone in Japanese
they're like oh that yeah
trying to communicate with us that's so
nice yeah like Sydney gets treated so
well when we go travel because she has
had this like eccentric weeb phase and
she's not afraid to do
um and like you know for a long time I
thought it was cringed here in Japan I'm
like [__] man that should have been me I
should have done that I could have got a
head start damn it yeah I noticed that
um because obviously when I started
learning Japanese more and speaking it
that um when I kind of copied the
mannerisms of uh like Japanese people
when they speak like a bit more quiet
bit more reserved
um that there are I don't know it was
like a lot harder to communicate and
sometimes there would like be walls
there but the moment I started kind of
speaking Japanese but also being way
more confident and more like kind of
just extroverted with it they're they're
super more chill about yeah they get way
more open to it yeah I think that's what
it is like yeah I think when they see
you speaking Japanese but still having
that kind of fun extroverted uh
personality with it I think it helps so
much yeah people are sure well because
they probably see that you're
comfortable yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah for
sure I kept telling me about hentai
basically what I realized after
returning after actually moving to Japan
we have to return to weeb that's we must
return to weave that was the hype with
it man yeah crazy if if you think you're
acting like [__] anime probably
Japanese people will actually be more
receptive yeah
maybe not online well maybe not all the
way no maybe not
but just like more eccentric more
confident don't end your sentences with
like this okay yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
no no not that far not that far even
Japanese people would be like okay
that's going too far away go back go
back I started I started using uh more
uh friendly uh what's the word when you
end the sentence uh what's the casual
you know what like yeah yeah when you
coming Gucci that's how you say like
yeah like the not casual one right not
okay yeah yeah I started doing it
speaking more casual like not saying
like the they're correct like they're
smarter I know those people are way more
receptive yeah and I I think it's purely
because I'm I'm white
yeah they're like more chill about it
than if I don't speak more natural yeah
because there's something about it
because you know when you when you when
you speak in like a keger like you know
this or whatever they probably think oh
you're maybe not as well versed in
Japanese or like not as comfortable
right because you sound like you learned
from a textbook which you probably did
but like if you speak in a casual way
they don't teach that [__] to you in the
textbooks yeah so to them it's like oh
you actually know how to speak like real
Japanese people and not from a textbook
right so that's probably what it is yeah
I started testing I'm testing some
things I've seen how it goes limit
testing yeah I wanted to see which
things worked
um one thing that didn't work or at
least some sometimes got me like weird
looks is that
I would uh
whenever I got out the taxi I'd leave
him I'd just say oh my thought
let's see you later oh you see you again
like a friend because I wanna I I just
kind of I wanted to see how it goes
that's like that's like being like peace
some of them some of them would laugh
and some of them would be like what yeah
what do you mean we've seen each other
again
yeah it's funny yeah
just trying fun things
updated yeah yeah I keep doing more
stuff yeah for sure
yeah thank you very much hey look at all
these patrons though do you see your
land I wonder how many of them agree
with Emily's takes let us know in the
comments which one you agree with if any
banana Goods I like how we uh I like
what we set up this podcast is an
intervention for you but then we just
ended up doing the usual thing of like
having [__] takes ourselves that's just
welcome to trash days yeah but hey if
you like to support the show then go
over to our patreon patreon.com trash
taste before Conor breaks our set also
follow us on Twitter send this to memes
on the subreddit and if you hate our
face to listen to us on Spotify and
obviously go check out Emily links in
the description
all right all right cool see you guys
next week
[Music]